are there any fans of political
corruption in tonight
because what a week it's been
um I don't know James if you know about
uh Boris Johnson
and the kangaroo court that saw him
being expelled against his wishes from
Parliament oh no he resigned of his own
accord
um there's Shenanigans going on in
Scotland Scotland
um and just when you thought it could
get any better
bellasconi died and but it all you know
it all goes back I think to one Donald
Trump who this week has been facing more
federal indictments and I thought if
only we could speak to someone who had a
working knowledge of how federal law
enforcement worked in America
and in particular with regard to the
Office of the President of the United
States so please welcome James Comey
um James just written a a fantastic
Thriller actually a real page Turner
called Central Park West
which as you'd expect the details of how
the uh the FBI and the law authorities
operate it feels very authentic and Rich
and detailed but you will probably know
him as the face of the inquiry into
Hillary Clinton's emails which seemed so
extraordinarily important at the time uh
but now isn't and then the person
the person who uh Donald Trump asked to
go easy on
um was it Michael Flynn
the his National Security advisor when
you were looking at when the FBI was
investigating potential links between
um uh the uh Trump campaign and Russia
so first of all
what's your reaction to where we are now
with Donald Trump is this is this bad
for him
I think it's bad for him legally I don't
know that it's bad for him politically
in seeking the Republican nomination but
if you read that indictment it's what we
call a speaking indictment so you now
know the evidence that the prosecutors
are going to put into evidence against
him the pictures are there the tapes are
there yeah and it's a strikes me as a
very very strong case he's in big
trouble Legally Legally because one of
his attorney general's bar said that
he's toast as far as these uh
indictments are yeah I hate to agree
with Bill Barr but I on this on this I
will that I think anybody
who cares to understand it after reading
it will understand he's in big trouble
you mentioned the difference between
legal trouble and political trouble
because he's saying that even if
indicted even if charged even a
convicted he's still going to run as
president is that is that possible under
the American Constitution it is being
convicted of a felony might actually
prevent him from voting for himself but
it doesn't
does not prevent it does not prevent him
from being a candidate for office
it's one less thing for him to think
about isn't it right yes a lot on his
plate yes but it's a yeah we're inside
if you wrote this in a screenplay it
would get rejected that that the
Republican Party might nominate such a
person but I think they might oh I'm so
glad I'm not writing Veep at the moment
because so much of what's Happening Now
is but there he is gaining momentum and
traction and you know turning it into
the Donald Trump show by saying there's
no evidence they've got nothing on me
wild pictures of classified documents in
boxes in his bathroom have been released
and we're at that stage because I
mentioned the Hillary Clinton email
thing we'll get on to that that seemed
so important and and you know people
were getting very very worked up about
it at the time that she might have used
emails or sent emails on a personal
server rather than this is the nuclear
codes sitting in his shower
and yet
why hasn't the world caved in what's
what's happened in those four or five
years to to turn that climate into one
where the reality is not something that
people take seriously because as to his
supporters which are a distinct minority
of Americans it's not about facts
they've been drawn into a cult really
and and so there's no way out for them
and every bad fact
is painful for them if they stare at it
and so they turn away January 6th the TV
Whispers to them you fool look what you
did you fool very few people can stare
at that most turn away I've had cases
where fraud victims showed up to support
the fraudster at sentencing because it's
so hard to admit about yourself that I
was a fool and so there are millions of
Americans for whom it doesn't matter
what you just said is absolutely true
about the difference between this and
the Clinton case it doesn't matter
because it's not about the facts for
those folks and so there's nothing
really to be done about that slice of
his followers they'll drift away
eventually write another story just as
Nick Nixon resigned 30 some percent
supported him but they found a way to
drift away from him and that that's what
it'll take with that hardcore group but
will he drift away in time for the next
election or is there still a real danger
I think it's a real a real prospect that
he will be the Republican nominee for
president I think it is very unlikely
that the American people in Even in our
slightly odd electoral vote system would
elect Donald Trump but it's a non-zero
chance which is why it's so important
the American people focus on what's
going to be on the ballot next year and
in a way they're not going to be able to
avoid focusing because he'll be front
and center in our lives again
um I mean you've met the guy up close uh
most notoriously that's a dinner or a
lunch where he sat you down and asked
you as head of the FBI to go easy to lay
up like you mentioned it's like the
language of a mobster really that that
sense of go easy on my guys you know
keep them you know that's bad bad
stereotype Italian mafia New York just
just I I actually I'm going to make a
complaint against myself for that sorry
but but
what I mean talk us through that moment
then you know when you're up close with
someone well that was actually the the
so-called loyalty dinner we were sitting
as close as you and I are alone they had
pushed all the furniture off to the side
of this cavernous Green Room in the
ground floor the base first floor excuse
me of the Residence at the White House
why what I don't know why this gigantic
rug with a tiny table and we faced each
other and he asked for directly asked me
to promise loyalty to him and I was so
surprised by it all I could think to do
was stare at the man
and so one beat two beats three beats of
silence and then he looked down and
started eating again and came back to it
but the purpose of that dinner was for
me to promise him that I was his FBI
director and so I didn't Focus much on
the food because the rest of the time I
was trying to make sure that I didn't
say anything that would reinforce that
idea do you think I mean there were no
notes take without would there be notes
taken at that launch show would you take
notes afterwards the moment I got in my
armored car I started writing down
everything that had been said okay
because I knew how significant that was
and I knew that it was the really the
end between the two of us because I
wouldn't give him what he wanted and it
wasn't just the stare but I to tell
Donald Trump anything you almost always
have to interrupt him and so I
interrupted him to tell him here's how
it has to work why it's so important to
have the Department of Justice have an
independent Spirit from the president
the American people have wanted it for
50 years since Jagger Hoover and he was
focused on his ice cream or something so
it didn't get through
when you say you had to interrupt him is
is that what he's like then is it just
an is it a kind of uh long flow of any
word that comes into his head what's the
yeah it's a long
again in my experience it's a long
verbal search for affirmation so he's
just constantly telling you things and
then saying right I'm right about that
I'm right about that and probably the
tensest moment that we had was he was
trying to get me sitting in the Oval
Office to agree that what he had said
about Putin was
fine when he had said you know America
we're Killers too and and I wouldn't
agree and I said Mr President actually I
I think that's wrong and that's that's
not a good description of the way we
conduct ourselves and it was almost like
a shadow across the room at that moment
and so I was surprised the day I was
fired I shouldn't have been surprised to
be fired were you where how did you get
the news
I was talking to employees in the Los
Angeles field office and I was a big
audience of FBI people and behind in
this training room there were three
televisions with no sound on tuned to
news channels
and while I'm speaking I start to notice
that the first one that it's I have to
relive this right now unfortunately but
it's all the TV monitors here it said
over on the TVs it said Comey resigns
and so I I you all don't know this but
there's a lot of very funny people in
the FBI and so I thought it was a
practical joke okay and so I turned to
the head of the LA office a woman that I
had promoted who I thought the world of
and I said that took a lot of work and
then I kept talking and then the
because I wasn't going to let them get
the better of me so I wanted to be a
good sport but I so I kept talking and
then I noticed it now said Comey fired
across all of them and I thought no
they're not going to go there
and so now all the employees are turning
around looking at the screens and I said
look I don't know whether that's true or
not I'm going to go find out but it
doesn't change what I want to say to you
and so I said some things about about
the quality of their work and then I
walked out
you could have maintained the uh the lie
you should you could have taken a cue
from your own president just like that
didn't happen it was all lies fake news
mainstream media didn't happen I'm still
here I wish you'd been there
I'm not going to leave
um
and and now and did you get a leaving
president present or did you uh I did
not I was allowed to fly home on the FBI
aircraft which infuriated
Trump he called my Deputy who
immediately became the acting director
and said he wanted an investigation as
to how I was allowed to come home on an
FBI plane and the deputy said like I
could investigate it but I can tell you
the answer right now I I authorized it
we're responsible for his protection we
can't leave him in L.A
and but the the uh Trump was Furious
about that yeah see that is an episode
of succession I think I think
I think one of the Roys takes a plane
and uh another Roy says he's not allowed
to do that but actually the the the the
the resign behind you I think we did do
that in the thick of it we didn't do it
in Veep but we did do Malcolm Tucker
says he's not resigning and then but the
news comes on right behind it
um it's funny now it's funny yeah
yeah what I mean but you said but
actually when you had the lunch you kind
of thought that is it though didn't you
the the the you know you know the tide
has turned and and yeah when I wouldn't
I mean the purpose of that was to to
extract a promise from me that I would
be no threat to him or any of his people
and then when I wouldn't agree to dump
the case against Michael Flynn that was
the second Stone in the load and then
the third I think was when I interrupted
him to tell him he was wrong about Putin
and America and then the fourth was he
wanted me to say publicly he wasn't
under investigation and I wouldn't do it
and so
um I and here's the way I misinterpreted
I thought he hates me good because that
means there'll be a distance between us
he won't be inviting me over for dinner
anymore but it tipped over into sort of
an irrational I need to get rid of this
guy but is this something I mean you
must have had dealings with him prior to
that obviously whether as president or
even in New York as a New York you must
have come up against him no I mean I met
him before he was president literally
President Obama sent
me the director of the CIA and the
director of the NSA up to New York to
Trump Tower the first week of January so
three weeks before he took office this
is during the transition right to tell
him what we had discovered about the
Russian interference in the election so
it wasn't a great beginning
[Music]
but yeah I'd never met the man before
obviously I knew who he was because his
name was plastered all over the place
yes he can never forget who he is can he
really
um but what is it this is something
never having met him but just reading so
many accounts of how he operates and is
there something sociopathic about him I
mean you talked about that continual
need for affirmation that even though he
hated you he'd still wants to get your
approval in a way your your it's that I
mean we have uh the the late dearly
departed Boris Johnson
we we had he seems to have that same he
doesn't have any friends but he wants
everyone to be his friend it's all about
people reflecting their approval of him
which is fine and one-to-one basis but
when it's the person who runs the
country it's a much more serious yeah I
don't I'm not in a position of
diagnosing but I I've never met and this
sounds like I'm being facetious but I
mean this I've never met an adult with a
greater hunger for affirmation it seemed
as if everything was about what can fill
this hole in me so there's some gigantic
hole in the middle of his identity that
I don't know where that comes from in
some ways it's it'd be sad if he wasn't
in the positions of power he has been
and wants to be again but that's that's
what I was struck by that I've never
your president of the United States yet
you're constantly working to get me to
say something good about you and that's
been his kind of downfall in a way aim
that he wants everyone's approval so
he's quite happy to have journalists
following him around he's quite happy to
have
I think the central uh piece of evidence
in in the current uh indictment is
there's a tape recordings of him saying
the things that he is on his social
media saying he didn't say yeah this
this kind of not not knowing when to
shut up he's not a very good
Mastermind is he he's he well I'm not
sure from moment to moment I I still
think the challenge in prosecutors
making cases that haven't been brought
yet the January 6 case is going to turn
on how do you prove the content of his
mind when even he may not know moment to
moment what he means or thinks about
something but which is why I long
thought that this document's case was
the greatest liability he faced because
it's so focused and once they have the
tape it's very easy for them to
establish it but what's unsaid in the
indictment is so what was his motive and
I think I could be convinced I don't
have any inside knowledge on this but I
could be convinced his motive was simply
to be able to fill that hole and show
you that I have these cool documents
even though that makes no sense you're
just a visiting journalist but to show
you that I have cool toys and so it's
about me yeah that's a strange thing
because he you know he was the president
he doesn't have to prove that he had
access to the nuclear codes you know we
would assume that that was the case I do
remember when we were researching feet
and we were shown Around The West Wing
and Obama's uh body man a rather large
guy called Reggie love yeah uh he was a
great guy
um and everyone goes around wearing
their surname on the lapel so he had
love really uh he was showing us around
The West Wing
but he would referencing the television
program The West Wing so he would say
this is the Roosevelt room this would be
where CJ and Josh would and I'm thinking
Obama would maybe have a conversation
with Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
and it's like
they need that sense of the outer World
they like the Showbiz element of it they
it's almost like they're they're not
sure that whether what they do is an
interesting enough job in itself being
the president and working in the West
Wing that they need this kind of
affirmation outside this recognition
that it's uh that it has there's a cat
there's a Charisma attached to it if um
if Hollywood can get hooked and I found
that you can have a fascinating slightly
disconnect between you know the power
that was there and and their attitudes
towards it really
I'm sure you didn't see that with Barack
Obama though right right was he very
confident I never I never met him but
yeah and I hadn't met him before he
interviewed me for FBI director but he
is one of the most secure people I've
ever dealt with and and he might say
this if he has a weakness it's maybe
overconfidence but he's not seeking
affirmation it's not a hole he's trying
to fill in himself which is what made
the the two of them yeah yes and
although you know it's easy to make
Trump a figure of fun and he's also
deathly serious isn't it the you've
since you were uh uh voluntarily uh
removed from the office of head of the
FBI you've really written a lot really
about the dangers that the potential
dangers and the threat to American
democracy as I've Arisen as a result of
what Trump has done and what his
followers have done yeah I thought I had
to yeah and I don't understand others
similarly situated who decided not to
speak out and but I can't judge them I
just thought I can't look my children or
grandchildren if I don't
say what I see what do you think what
damage do you think has happened already
and and what more could happen if there
was a second term Trump
I think he has eroded a norm In America
which is that we that there is a
touchstone the truth is real there is a
touchstone that is the truth and we
measure our leaders by their tether to
that Touchstone you know when Barack
Obama said something about health
insurance it was inaccurate he was held
accountable he had to explain the danger
I saw in Trump and still see is that the
lies are so
so extensive that they could wash away
the Touchstone and we would stop judging
without even realizing it but drop the
norm that it matters whether our leaders
tell the truth or not and so he did that
by beating down the Press by constantly
constantly reinforcing the
preconceptions of the members of his
political cult and it's a it's a long
walk back from a place where we've lost
that at the center of American life then
on top of that closer to my work is he's
intentionally taken a flamethrower to
the Department of Justice and the FBI
for reasons that I understand if you
think about his world view he knew if a
threat was going to come to him that's
where it would come and so he would prep
that Battlefield by burning it down long
in advance and now he's pulling on those
reserves among his supporters I told you
they were corrupt I told you they were
evil and that's a dangerous place to be
because you can criticize it should
criticize government institutions but
we need to see those Justice
institutions as separate from the
political and he's made sure I mean even
to say this if you put this in a script
to be rejected the notion that the FBI
is a bunch of
leftists bent on destroying Republicans
in the United States is so crazy that
just to say it out loud seems silly but
there are millions of Americans who
believe that because it's been repeated
over and over and over again so among I
could go on with the depressing list but
that's probably enough right now what's
what's your what's your biggest worry if
there was a second Trump president
saying what what more damage could he do
he
I'm loath to be too prescriptive because
I can see ways that he could do more
damage also you don't want to give him
ideas correct
correct I think the danger maybe I'll
just say it in this way
I think he understands better how things
work
and his Supporting Cast would be even
deeper towards the bottom of the barrel
than the last time and so he would be
the retribution president with a better
understanding of the levers of power
surrounded by a group of people who are
looking to burn it all down and our
system would survive that but he could
do things that would be much more
lasting damage they did the last time
the worrying thing that I'm reading is
that his Camp campaign team are actually
much more
focused and much more effective and
efficient than the rather kind of ragbag
team that he had in 2016 because I think
they signed up think it would be a jolly
Adventure yeah and we're not going to
win but it'll be a laugh whereas this
lot now that he has he's cleared out
either he's cleared out or his family
have cleared themselves out but there's
no sign of Ivanka and although it's it's
very very hard-nosed thorough highly
professional campaigners and and that's
that's the worrying thing you I mean you
mentioned a cult the Republican and you
had you were previously registered as as
a republican voter you you've been a
republican voter yeah correct so how do
you feel about the Republican party
because you know they're not they're not
doing much to stop this we've had
Republicans there was a Republican
representative who talked about how the
the FBI should be defunded and
dismantled you know defunding the police
was the was the criticism Mantra that
the right used against the left
four or five years ago as something that
the you know the uh the extremists left
we're talking about but here's a
republican yeah talking about
dismantling defunding I don't think the
Republican Party exists anymore in the
United States and and some sign of that
is the last time there was a Republican
presidential campaign they didn't have a
platform but they don't stand for
anything that's why I wasn't being again
trying to be wise and calling it a cult
it is a cult of personality and it's
just about
hating and grievance and it's centered
on this person and so it's hard to even
recognize it now there's still
Republican office holders and most of
them want to keep their office enough
that they will say or do anything to
placate the base because the base could
deprive of their office by voting
against them in a primary election and
so there's a there's a cynical deeply
cynical crust at the top and then a
whole lot of people who've been
harvested by a demagogue this was the
great fear of the founders in America
and we're seeing a once not just in a
lifetime once in many lifetimes
demagogue and he will not succeed but it
sounds contradictory but
to assure you he's not going to succeed
in being elected president but only if
the American people participate the way
they did last time and to recognize the
danger they face CNN got a lot of
criticism for its Town Hall in the
states and I had a difference they did
that with with Trump did that the idea
was you gave him a platform and my view
is
no I like that because I want the
American people to see you cannot take
this election off and think well we
fixed that because the threat is in some
ways more severe but what where did you
know Republicans uh normal I've got to
call you normal Republican normal
Republicans like you who I think have a
clear sense of uh it's everything in
your whole career which I'll go to in a
second sense of public duty
um the importance of uh serving the
community
um there's a whole sense of Republican
family values that clearly aren't
manifested in Donald Trump so where do
they go if you as you say the real
Republican party has has disappeared
Well for now all thoughtful principled
Republicans need to go and most have
gone
to address the threat I mean I
campaigned for Joe Biden and they should
do so again because this is above any
policy disagreements I mean we have
robust disagreements in America but as
you do here but all kinds of policy
issues okay great that's what a
democracy should be about but above
those disagreements are things that are
common ground the rule of law for
example and so the voting and the
activism has to be aimed at that and
we'll get back to important
disagreements about taxation or
regulation but those things pale in
comparison to the threat to the thing
above and are you worried that you know
Biden is even older than Trump he he's
beginning to look frailer now
do you think people will come out for
Biden
I do as they did last time because
sort of a backhanded compliment but he's
a lot better than the alternative and so
I think people will come out and say
well I wish he was younger I wish it was
Kamala Harris I wish it was Pete
butterjudge or somebody fine
but he's the candidate and so what
you're always choosing I forget who said
don't oh Joe Biden says don't choose
between me and the almighty choose
between me and the alternative and so
given who the alternative is likely to
be
it's really important that people
recognize that's the choice and engage
on it don't take this one off and I
again Lincoln was fond of quoting his
secretary of state during the Civil War
who said there's always enough virtue in
America to save her and then he paused
and said but just enough
that was a description of our country in
1863. it's still a fair description of
America we'll be okay because it's
enough virtue but there isn't a surplus
of virtue that allows people to take an
election off
I'm I suddenly got a flashback when you
said we'll be okay I got a rather
pressure flashback because when we were
researching Veep we got a lot of advice
from Ron Klein who was Joe Biden Vice
President Biden's chief of staff at the
time and Obama he gives a lot of time
looking around
uh the officers of the vice president
you know talking to us about what life
is like as a vice president he said
America is always about being number one
but as vice president you're more or
less going around with a metaphorical
pin saying number two and it's the
effect it has but Ron clean then went on
to work on the Hillary Clinton's
campaign I don't remember
messaging him the night before the
election saying good luck and he replied
we'll be okay and so I just remember
those words we'll be okay the night
before Trump went and of course she did
win the popular vote but of course the
way the system works in America with the
college vote uh Trump one and that's I
think where the rest of the world first
got to see you it was the Hillary
Clinton campaign uh whereas head of the
FBI you revised lucinto and I said I'm
not sure any of us really understood
what the problem was there was issues
with emails servers
bad enough for Donald Trump at the time
to say lock her up
despite the fact that you know four
years on he's got the nuclear codes in
his bathroom
um what was that what was first of all
what was that like being in the
spotlight like that not just for you as
a head of the FBI but but profession but
but personally as well really it's not
something you ask for when you take on
the job I suppose no you you expect that
because it's the FBI you're going to be
involved in things that are going to be
controversial I can remember the day
that my Deputy briefed me on the fact
that this the Clinton email
investigation and it was about the
question of when the secretary secretary
Clinton communicated on an unclassified
email system is actually not about it
being her server when she communicated
on an unclassified system about
classified topics did that rise to the
level of a crime and I remember him
telling me the case had been opened well
below me despite what you see on TV the
director doesn't investigate and he said
as he turned to walk out of my office he
turned back and said you know you're
totally screwed right
and I I kind of laughed and I said yep
nobody gets out alive but what he meant
was we're about to begin a criminal
investigation of one of the two likely
candidates for president of the United
States
one half of the politically active are
going to be unhappy with the results
I had no idea we could make both halves
unhappy by the time we were done but but
one half of it shows how impossible you
are right yeah if everyone's against it
but it's gonna he said you know and in a
way that was freeing that we knew that
and so I talked about this with the team
and I said do the work in a professional
way let me worry about how we're going
to explain it how we're going to defend
it just do it well and they worked for
the next year without we didn't talk
about it and no one knew what we were
doing and but I knew that when we got to
the end and I saw no prosecutable case
there for reasons that any person who
wishes to see could understand and its
distinction to the Trump situation I
knew that that was going to be
um in the middle of a political storm
which is why I spent so much time
offering transparency to explain to the
American people consistent with our
policies here's what we did here's what
we found here's why this is not a
prosecutable case and then spent the
rest of the summer getting attacked on
Capitol Hill by Republicans as I
defended the work and said no we're done
we're done this is over there's no there
there election can go on we're out of it
and then that turned out and then 11
days before the election yeah turned out
not to be true you wrote there was a
letter issued by you saying that you had
to reopen the investigation now first of
all I mean you must have known that that
was such a sensitive moment that uh you
know just 11 days to go before the
election the polls showing you know it
wasn't it wasn't a kind of um it was a
very tight race I think people still
thought Clinton would win but there was
a margin that was very small so you knew
you were stepping into something much
more sensitive and oh gosh I knew the
moment I remember I could picture myself
the moment walking into the room on
October 27th that my team telling me
that we have now found hundreds of
thousands of secretary Clinton's emails
and I hope you all don't know these
details but on this guy Anthony Weiner's
laptop and we know about Anthony Weiner
sorry sorry but and that we we also see
on there although we've not been allowed
to look at them yet the emails from her
missing blackberry and so they said look
the Department of Justice is reopened
they want to get a search warrant we
don't think we can review them we know
we can't review them before the election
and we think the result might change and
you told Congress under oath repeatedly
this is done this is done and you can
trust us at the FBI so now what do I do
and I could see two options and they
were both doors to hell I mean I could I
could say nothing which would be an act
of concealment given that I testified
that we're done and let the American
people vote not knowing that I know that
what they're relying on is a lie or I
could speak which is also a door to hell
and maybe have an impact on the election
because people would misunderstand what
we were saying and so reasonable people
can disagree about those but I hope
people who stare at it can see just what
a nightmare it was so to come back to
your question you asked how did it feel
it was numbing but also in a way freeing
because I thought both of these options
are so bad
so bad that I simply have to choose the
one that's least bad and most consistent
with the values of the institution and
so I will try to do that and then I
tried to dump it on my boss
because I thought you know this is going
to be so bad for me personally so a
little moment of cowardice that I'm
confessing and so I asked my chief of
staff to call the Attorney General's
chief of staff and say Here's what he
thinks but he would welcome a
conversation with her and the answer
came back she disagrees but she does not
wish to speak to him
and I knew what that was I mean I've
been around I knew that was you will
take this hit and that was part of what
made it so my wife so upset because she
was asking me why you why does it have
to be you
and
there was no alternative that I even in
hindsight as painful as it is despite
the the uh the fact that some people
believe although I'm I'm not sure that's
the case some people believe it helped
Donald Trump get elected I still think
about the decision the same way I I
think knowing what I knew then
I can't conceal I have to speak